have you seen this it's been popping up
there's admin plants for men yo
apparently this is a one point
three billion dollar industry no no 1.3
million men went in for cosmetic surgery
now I'd like to know what percentage of
that is Botox because I think that
that's as we predicted become incredibly
popular yeah
everybody 100
LA and uh uh Soho nolita New York
you really narrowed down wait did I
narrow it up to kind of like hit yeah am
I well this [__] is gone but for a
minute when I was looking good that is
too strong bro you look like you got a
hair treatment going down below
hold up [__] anyway I'd like to know
what that is yo it's hard being Waluigi
out here man it's hard yo how the hell
did they make a Mexican
um look good
I think that is aren't built to look
good in the body like that Mexicans
y'all know what the [__] I'm talking
about you're not built with abs so what
what's the procedure so that lipo
obviously and then are they putting
something in yeah I think they're
re-injecting fat like fat transfer like
BBL no way that seems crazy I also think
they have prosthetic too yeah but they
accused uh liver king of doing that yeah
and uh here's how big is
yeah some are actual implants and I
think what they can also do is like uh
they tighten on like uh to create
contouring yeah yeah stuff there's still
hope bro but a lot of people on this and
you put them in control do we go back
into a competition by the way yeah we
might need to but this is something that
I'm really upset about because
what does love hand no no no like dudes
doing this cosmetic ship the great thing
about being a dude was always that we
just needed to get successful yeah right
yeah that we could we could we could be
[__] fat we could be
ugly we could be short we could be
anything this is dudes doing it for
dudes
hold on one second hold on one second I
want to hear that point let me get out
my point that I feel like is shitty now
okay
one of the great things was that we had
access out of the cards that God dealt
us yeah so God Delta certain cards but
we had access out and that was the great
thing because women don't right like
they ugly they ugly right now I know
that we could get them on that HRT and
we can make them more beautiful we gotta
try that [__] but
you bring up a very interesting point
Alex yeah which is this is men trying to
impress other men please elaborate so
most women say they're not Intel all the
big muscles Cuts all that [__] most
women I have a theory on that really
quickly like I've heard women say like
they're into dad Bots well I think it's
a insecurity complex I think if the guy
is better in better shape than them oh
really they feel insecure a little bit
and I don't think that they need us to
be shredded in order to be turned on so
when we are and they're not and it's
much harder for them to be in shape than
us like they naturally store fat because
they have to have children with it like
I think it makes them a little bit
insecure anyway interesting oh no
because I just remember like when Zac
Efron was all like roided up and [__]
like that and like women were like
they're not into that I think that far
that way like I saw like a man on the
street video type of thing and it was
like four bodies like super shredding
bodybuilder and then like a very fit guy
then Dad bod and then a really out of
shape person yeah everyone pick the
first to be just a really in shape dude
yeah a lot of girls were like they could
not handle all of that hyper yeah I
think Ellie's not protruding but I don't
think you need [__] six-pack
especially that don't look real who's
that whatever a rapper that went viral
that's Batman Kevo right yeah he was
just honest about it and then people
I just I don't know how you know this
guy but must have happened
do you know how I know one because he
was talking that [__] he was like oh
y'all made fun of me for getting my body
done but now 1.3 million men have just
admitted that they went out and did it
so he basically got his get back also
his titties are mad recognizable
he got a recognizable chest yeah wait
the chest is fake too I think the whole
thing is done yeah
but it looks good though
like that you built like that a little
bit come on you are built like that my
chest ain't that big did you come out of
chest yeah because I [__] work out
but not like did you get [__]
transfer it does don't do it did you
stop did you transfer from your legs
[Laughter]
I need to do can you get someone else's
fat pudding you what's the rules on that
like could you do BBL that was a joke I
had about the Kardashians that they were
using Rob yeah that's funny he was a
source for all their titties I don't
know my concern with this is that we're
gonna do what women have done and women
have absolutely destroyed themselves as
they've created an unrealistic standard
for themselves yeah they have the fake
eyelashes they're wearing [__] heels
all the time they're wearing Spanx to
keep their stomach and they're doing all
these things now I understand that being
good looking is more valuable for them
in the marketplace it's a the currency
is more valuable than us being good
looking sure but my fear is if we are
expected to look like this now we're
going to put ourselves in the same
situation they do where they're spending
an hour to get [__] ready there's
going to doctor's appointments all the
[__] time the great thing about being
a dude is we get to focus on our job
have a dad bod as long as we get to you
know some good money coming in and we
could provide more value do you think
this is part of like the dating app
culture that like where if it's just a
meat market like before you could be
like Charming hey don't say do you think
stand on that brilliant thing that you
just said this is the symptom
of dating app culture yes yeah that's
what they say why why because dating
apps is just a meat
markets specifically he just always
happens to bring that up but back in the
day it used to be Charming you could
just go up to a girl no you just
you're more Charming than you are good
looking
I mean but I'm really really charming
and also that's what I said about you
what have I said that's the perfect
color what if I sounded weird
the most charismatic Charming his social
IQ is the highest that exists on the
planet have I always said that 10 yeah
11 12. yeah you're more Charming than
you are good looking Fair take it what's
his NBA 2K score like he's 100 out of
100 for Charming and then where is he at
percentage-wise
for like looks I think he's 150 out of
100 and Charming nice and I think when
you average it with his looks he's about
an 85.
and then personality brings me about
like a five
you're definitely coming down
we've really gonna let him go nine out
of 10 looks right now
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
no I will honestly because I don't know
how to do the whatever talks I don't
even know what you want to do yeah small
talk so I need to be like what do you
want like I'm very quick in the
conversation what do you want to do hey
we just sat down hey great to meet you I
got a joke you need to get out go go get
your joke
haircuts okay
it was so funny when you were trying to
be all sentimental of like uh how you
knew this was my wife it was like the
first time I actually wanted to listen
to somebody
that would do it before I didn't want
him I know it was probably no so it was
rough bro yeah I looked up I got out of
the first time yeah
imagine having hundreds of women
hundreds hundreds hundreds actually
maybe some of them I like listen to
but how do you not know
I think not yeah they're not here no no
that sounds bad I'm joking this is jokes
Gravity Park
but there's someday I just didn't like
that because I was always nice and kind
yeah
I knew some didn't want to listen to me
yo ain't that crazy they just wanted to
get [__] down yeah they go straight up
yo I'm telling you there are women that
just tolerated
a girl you're like she didn't care about
my dreams she did bro
s they got they got
a sexual appetite this crazy son y'all
don't know bro I don't know they'll be
single girls in New York
you're telling her about your dreams
and [__] that happened at a show once
and she just started making out with me
in the middle of it I'll bombed twice
now my cough is slow I can't dig this
girl down yeah but she's trying to suck
your tongue she's trying to treat you
like the Dalai Lama